SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN BROUGHT TO YOU. ARCHULETTA.
ST HACKINGS BECKER. BLACK SPEAR.
BRADFORD. CAVIAR Ó. ORTEZ E.
DAILY. DODD. THERE ARE SO
HAGMAN. GLASER. HE'S ALWAYS
GROVE. OR DATO. JONES. LAYERED
LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. WHEN NEIL Ó. PHÐ BOAT.
TODAVÍA PORTANTINO ROD. RUBIO.
SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALL GRABBERS
STERN. HAMBURG HOB WIENER.
WELCOME. MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO ASK
EVERYBODY TO PLEASE RISE. AT
THIS MOMENT FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE. FOR THE FIVE MARINES
WHO WERE KILLED IN A TRAGIC
HEALTH HELICOPTER CRASHED IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. AH! VERY RECENTLY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. LIKE THAT.
ASK EVERYONE TO REMAIN STANDING.
WE'RE GONNA BE LET IN PRAYER
TODAY THIS MORNING BY CHAPLAINS
SISTER, MICHELE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. GRACIOUS GOD. AS WE
CELEBRATE ANOTHER LUNAR NEW
YEAR, THE YEAR OF THE DRAGON. WE
GIVE THANKS FOR THE CHANGING OF
THE SEASONS AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RESET OUR ATTITUDES AND
PERSPECTIVES. AS VISIONARY
LEADERS HELP US TO LIVE INTO
THIS NEW YEAR WITH THE QUALITIES
OF THE DRAGON. VITALITY AND
STRENGTH TO FACE THE CHALLENGES
AHEAD. FORESEEN AND UNFORESEEN.
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
SEEMINGLY UNRESOLVABLE ISSUES.
AND CONFIDENCE TO KNOW THAT ALL
IS HELD IN YOUR LOVE AND MERCY.
WE THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT HAS
BEEN ACCOMPLISHED IN THE PAST
YEAR. AND WE ASK YOUR
ACCOMPANIMENT AS WE SEEK TO
BRING SAFETY, HEALING AND
PROSPERITY TO ALL THOSE WE
SERVE. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME.
AMEN. HMM. THANK YOU. SISTER
GORMAN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. STATES OF AMERICA.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH OUR AGENDA PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED BREAD. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. I DON'T
SEE ANY MICROPHONES UP. MOVE
NEXT TO INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS. BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOVE NEXT TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
THEIR SENATOR, THIRD READING, I
HAVE NUMBER SEVEN CLERK. PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION 59 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN RELATIVE TO THE
SPECIAL SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
PROGRAM FOR WOMEN, INFANTS AND
CHILDREN. SENATOR NEWMAN. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO RESENT S R
59, WHICH COMMEMORATES THE 50TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SPECIAL
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION PROGRAM
FOR WOMEN, INFANTS AND CHILDREN
WERE COLLOQUIALLY REFERRED TO AS
WEAK AND CELEBRATES ITS
INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTION TO THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF MOTHERS
, INFANTS AND CHILDREN IN OUR
STATE SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN
1974 WEEK, HAS BEEN A BEACON OF
SUPPORT TO CALIFORNIA'S
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE. HEALTH CARE
REFERRALS. BREASTFEEDING SUPPORT
NUTRITION EDUCATION IN RELIEF IN
TIMES OF CRISIS TO PARENTS AND
YOUNG CHILDREN IN NEED. WIC IS
MUCH MORE THAN A HUNGER
PREVENTION PROGRAM FOR
PARTICIPANTS, IT IS PIVOTAL IN
ENSURING HEALTHY PREGNANCIES
SUPPORTING POST NATAL CARE,
FOSTERING EARLY CHILDHOOD
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT AND
SETTING THE STAGE FOR FUTURE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE WEEK PROGRAM SERIES. NEARLY
1 MILLION VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVERS, INFANTS AND CHILDREN
PER MONTH WHILE CHANNELING MORE
THAN $70 MILLION IN HEALTHY FOOD
PURCHASES PER MONTH THROUGH
LOCAL GROCERY STORES, FARMERS
MARKETS AND MILITARY
COMMISSARIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WAKE. DONNELLY SUPPORTS
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES BUT ALSO
BENEFITS OUR STATE'S ECONOMY AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WEEK IS AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR NATION'S
FUTURE, ENSURING THAT
PARTICIPANTS ARE HEALTHY AND
ABLE TO THRIVE. CALIFORNIANS CAN
BE VERY PROUD OF THE FIVE
DECADES OF SERVICE PROVIDED BY
LOCAL WEEK AGENCY STAFF. AND
THEY SHOULD CONTINUE TO EMBRACE
WICK IS AN IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
PARTNER. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE 50TH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE WIC PROGRAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEWMAN. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. I THINK I'M IN CLERK.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
WROTE A GILL. I GOT YOUR LETTER.
AYE, ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. I BECKER
BLAKE SPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
AYE. CAVIAR. OH, COURTESY. I
DOLLY. AYE, DODD. THERE IS OH,
HAGMAN. AYE, GLASER. I ALWAYS I
GROVE OR 0.0. BY JONES. HI,
LAIRD. HI, LIMÓN. AYE, MCGUIRE.
I MENJIVAR. MEN. AYE, NEWMAN. I
WIN. I KNEEL Ó. AYE, KOBACH.
PORTANTINO ROD. AYE, RUBIO. AYE,
SEYARTO. AYE, SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL QUIVERS. AYE, STERN. I
HAMBURG BY HOB. AYE WIENER. I
WILL. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER. CAVIAR
Ó. DODD. HI THERE AS Ó. LOVE.
AYE. MENJIVAR. KOBO. VIDEO. AYE,
PORTANTINO. ON A BOAT OF 34 TO
0. THE RESOLUTIONS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. AND
THIS WOULD BE THE TIME TO
ADDRESS THE JOURNEY IN MEMORIES.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO. SENATOR
ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
LET ME START RIGHT OFF THE BAT
BY SAYING THIS IS A TOUGH ONE
FOR ME. SO THANKS FOR BEARING
WITH ME. I RISE TODAY TASK THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND LAUREN HAMMOND. SHE
PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY ON
JANUARY 18TH AT THE AGE OF 68.
LAUREN WAS AN ICONIC SACRAMENTO
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER. SHE ALSO
WORKED HERE. AS SENATE STAFF FOR
MORE THAN TWO DECADES. SHE WAS A
BELOVED MEMBER OF THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY. LAUREN LEFT BEHIND
HER LOVING WIFE OF MANY YEARS,
MARGARET. WHO SHE MET IN 1981
HERE IN SENATE SPECIAL SERVICES.
SHE ALSO LEFT BEHIND HER
SIBLINGS MARCIA, DAVID CARROLL
AND KEVIN SISTER IN LAW, ROBIN.
HER AUNT FRAN, COUSIN RUBIN AND
NIECES EMILY AND LINDSEY, MOST
OF WHOM, ALONG WITH OTHER
FRIENDS ARE HERE WITH US IN THE
GALLERY TODAY. LAUREN WAS BORN
IN LOS ANGELES, WHERE SHE LIVED
UNTIL THE AGE OF 13. WHEN SHE
MOVED TO SACRAMENTO. SHE SPOKE
OFTEN OF THE DEEP IMPRESSION THE
WATTS RIOTS LEFT ON HER YOUNG
HEART AND MIND. LIVING THROUGH
THAT HISTORIC MOMENT. WOULD
LATER DRIVE HER EFFORTS ON THE
SACRAMENTO CITY COUNCIL. TO FIND
BALANCE AND TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS A GRADUATE OF CK
MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL. AND
ATTENDED SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
BEFORE EARNING HER BACHELOR OF
ARTS DEGREE FROM SAC STATE. SHE
WORKED FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE FOR 22 YEARS. AS A
CONTRACT ADMINISTRATOR AND OUR
SPECIAL SERVICES DIVISION. THEN
SHE SERVED IN A VARIETY OF
PROFESSIONAL POSITIONS WITH THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES. AND
AS THE SENATE COORDINATOR FOR
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT. LAUREN WAS A TRAILBLAZER.
IN 1997. SHE MADE HISTORY AS THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN EVER ELECTED
TO SERVE ON SACRAMENTO CITY
COUNCIL. LAUREN ALSO SERVED IN
MANY LOCAL AND STATE
ORGANIZATIONS, SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA'S GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION, SACRAMENTO'S
REGIONAL TRANSIT, OUR COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND OUR METROPOLITAN
AIR DISTRICT, JUST TO NAME A
FEW. LAUREN WAS ADMIRED. FOR
SHARING HER WISDOM AND
EXPERIENCE THROUGH MENTORSHIP.
GUIDING MANY WOMEN ON THEIR
JOURNEYS OF PUBLIC SERVICE,
INCLUDING ME. THE FIRST TIME
THAT I MET LAUREN HAMMOND WAS IN
2010. I HAD JUST WON A
CONTENTIOUS RACE TO SERVE ON THE
SACRAMENTO CITY COUNCIL. SHE WAS
LEAVING THE CITY. SO WE ONLY HAD
A FEW WEEKS AS COLLEAGUES. BUT
SHE MADE A BIG IMPRESSION ON ME.
SHE OBSERVED MY PREDECESSOR,
REMOVING ANY HISTORY OF THE
DISTRICT PRIOR TO MY ARRIVAL.
AND DECIDED THAT SHE WOULD GO
THROUGH HER OWN MATERIALS. AND
FIND ANYTHING THAT MIGHT HELP ME
GET A GOOD START. SHE SAID IT
ASIDE FOR ME IN ONE CARDBOARD
BOX. I BUILT IT. 12 YEAR CAREER
OF SERVICE TO MY CITY. STARTING
ONLY WITH THE CONTENTS OF THAT
BOX. LAUREN HELPED MANY WOMEN
SERVE OUR REGION. SHE LED THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS FOR SEVERAL YEARS. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT COURAGEOUSLY
WALKS WITH WOMEN CANDIDATES
THROUGH TOUGH CAMPAIGNS. SHE WAS
HUMBLE. GENUINE. KIND. LOYAL.
AND COMMITTED TO UPHOLDING THE
STRONG PRINCIPLES ESTABLISHED IN
HER YOUTH. SHE CARRIED THOSE
STANDARDS WITH HER ALL OF HER
LIFE. SHE WAS DEEPLY DEVOTED TO
HER FAMILY. AND ENJOYED SPENDING
TIME WITH RELATIVES AND FRIENDS.
SHE WAS A LOYAL ADVOCATE AND
SUPPORTER OF THOSE SEX STATE
HORNETS, HER ALMA MATER. SHE
ENJOYED GOLFING GOING ON CRUISES
SINGING DANCING, ESPECIALLY TO
JAMES BROWN. A LOVER OF SPORTS.
SHE DUTIFULLY CHEERED FOR HER
CHILDHOOD SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TEAMS, THE RAMS AND THE DODGERS.
BUT EVER THE CALIFORNIAN SHE WAS
READY TO ROOT FOR THE NINERS IN
THE SUPER BOWL THIS YEAR. I LAST
SPOKE TO LAUREN JUST HOURS
BEFORE SHE CLOSED HER EYES FOR
THE LAST TIME. IRONICALLY, HER
LAST MESSAGE TO ME. WAS TO SAY
HOW GREAT SHE WAS FEELING. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED. OR WHY
HER TIME WAS CUT SO SHORT. AND
WITHOUT WARNING. BUT WHAT I DO
KNOW IS THAT SHE WAS HAPPY. AND
DEEPLY IN LOVE WITH YOU,
MARGARET. LAUREN WAS THE KIND OF
FRIEND WHO CARED ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF YOUR LIFE. NOT JUST
THE HEADLINES. BUT THE CONTEXT
SHE CHECKED IN REGULARLY.
PROVIDED ENCOURAGEMENT AND WAS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO TALK,
PREFERABLY OVER A GOOD GLASS OF
WINE. THOSE KIND OF FRIENDS. THE
ONES YOU HAVE YOUR BACK EVEN
WHEN YOU'RE NOT IN THE ROOM.
THOSE RARE SOULS ARE
IRREPLACEABLE. I'M LUCKY AND
GRATEFUL TO HAVE KNOWN LAUREN.
AND HONORED TO HAVE MARGARET'S
FRIENDSHIP AS WELL. LAWRENCE
PASSION. SPIRIT AND HEART ARE
ALREADY MISSED BEYOND MEASURE BY
ALL WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
KNOWING HER. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. I OFFER
OUR SINCEREST CONDOLENCES TO
LAWRENCE SWEET MARGARET. AND TO
HER FAMILY. AND TO ALL WHO WERE
TOUCHED BY HER INCREDIBLE LIFE.
MY FRIEND, SACRAMENTO CITY
COUNCILWOMAN, TRAILBLAZER AND
ICON LAUREN HAMMOND. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ASHBY. WE WELCOME
MARGARET. AND FRIENDS OF LAUREN
HAMMOND HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
BEING A PART. OF OUR DAY TO DAY
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING
LAUREN, BOTH AS A MEMBER OF
UNDERCLASS. MINUTES, HE CAME
MCCLATCHY AND AS A JUNIOR
STAFFER HERE IN THE BUILDING,
WORKING FOR THE SENATE AND
HAVING A VISIT WITH HER AND THAT
HIGH POSITION OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND SHE'S A
WONDERFUL PERSON. AND SHE WILL
BE DEEPLY MISSED. SENATOR ASHBY.
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO
SHE CAN BE PROPERLY MORALIZING,
THE SENATE JOURNAL. ON THE SAME
EXCUSE ME, SENATOR, SENATOR NEAL
Ó. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I
GOT TO KNOW LAUREN WHILE I WAS
ON THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS, AND SHE WAS ON
THE CITY COUNCIL AND WE SERVED
ON A FEW JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES TOGETHER AND, UH SHE
REALLY BECAME A VERY GOOD FRIEND
. UM A PERSON PASSIONATE ABOUT
HER POLITICAL VIEWS AND WE
DISAGREED ON SOME OF THOSE. BUT
SHE HAD A TREMENDOUS SENSE OF
HUMOR. AND UH WE DID BECOME
PRETTY CLOSE FRIENDS AND WE
WOULD SORT OF TEASE EACH OTHER.
FROM TIME TO TIME, AND I WAS
FOUND HER A REALLY FUN PERSON.
BE AROUND. AND ONE STORY THAT I
REMEMBER IN PARTICULAR WAS A
SUNDAY I WENT TO MY SON'S HOUSE
WHO AT THE TIME LIVED IN
HOLLYWOOD PARK, AND THERE WERE
PRECINCT WALKERS THERE, AND IT
WAS IN LAWRENCE DISTRICT, AND SO
, UM, I WENT TO ONE OF THEM, AND
I SAID, IS LAUREN OUT HERE,
KNOCKING ON DOORS? SHE SAID.
YES, SHE IS. AND I SAID, HAVE
HER COME TO THIS HOUSE, SO I
WENT INSIDE AND WITH MY FAMILY
AND KNOCKED ON THE DOOR AND SO I
WENT TO THE DOOR AND I THREW THE
DOOR OPEN. LAUREN WAS THERE AND
I SAID, I KNOW YOUR NEW
NEIGHBOR. AND SHE SAID, OH,
SHOOT! BUT SHE DIDN'T SAY SHOOT.
AH BUT THAT WAS HER. SHE WAS A
FUNNY PERSON AND A FUN PERSON.
AND MY FRIEND FROM SACRAMENTO
WAS NICE ENOUGH TO CALL ME WHEN
SHE HEARD THAT LAUREN HAD PASSED
AWAY. I WAS SHOCKED WAY TOO
YOUNG AND I ALSO OFFER MY
CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY UP IN
THE GALLERY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEELA. NEXT UP. WE'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE SENATOR FROM SAN
JOSE SENATOR CORTEZ. PURPOSES OF
A JOURNEY MEMORY. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS RISE TO A
JOURNEY MEMORY OF JEFF MARGOLIS,
LIFELONG PUBLIC SERVANT. WHO
PASSED ON NOVEMBER 26 AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF 60. JEFF WAS BORN
IN SACRAMENTO AFTER MOVING TO
PAOLO ALTO, KANSAS CITY IN
DENVER, HIS FAMILY RETURNED TO
SACRAMENTO WHEN HE WAS A
SOPHOMORE IN HIGH SCHOOL. THOUGH
HE MET HIS WIFE, KRISTIN, WHEN
THEY WERE 19 AND IT'S 17. THEY
RECONNECTED IN THE 19 NINETIES
AND LATER GOT MARRIED IN 2001.
JEFF WAS HAPPIEST AT HOME. WITH
HIS WIFE AND AROUND THEIR TWO
KIDS. HE LOVES SPORTS, SERVING
AS A COACH TO HIS SON'S SOCCER,
BASK BASKETBALL AND BASEBALL
TEAMS. HE WAS A BRUINS, 40,
NINERS, KINGS AND SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS FAN. JUST FATHER, GARY
MARGOLIS WAS CHIEF OF STAFF. THE
SPEAKER JESSEN THROUGH SO JEFF
CAN SEE THE VALUE OF PUBLIC
SERVICE THROUGH HIS OWN FAMILY.
AND HE CHOSE TO CONTINUE THAT
LEGACY. WHICH, OF COURSE WE ALL
KNOW HE UPHELD. BEGINNING IN
JUNE. 2022 JEFF WORKED AS CHIEF
COUNSEL TO THE MIDDLE HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. AS A
MEMBER OF THE COMMISSION. MYSELF
REPRESENTING THE SENATE. I COULD
SEE FIRST HAND THE IMPACT OF HIS
WORK AND THE TRANSFORMATIONAL
BENEFIT PROVIDED TO OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. HIS PASSION FOR
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIANS WAS
CLEAR, AND HE WAS AN INSPIRATION
TO OTHERS DOING THIS WORK.
BEFORE HIS TIME WITH THE
COMMISSION. HE SPENT MORE THAN
20 YEARS WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. IN
SEVERAL ROLES, INCLUDING
PROVIDING DIRECT LEGAL ADVICE TO
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. EVEN WORKED IN
BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGISLATURES. JEFF ADVOCATED FOR
COMMUNITIES FACING
DISCRIMINATION. HE HELPED
DEVELOP IN THE DARK REGULATIONS
COVERING MENTAL HEALTH PARITY.
GENDER NON DISCRIMINATION,
HEALTHCARE AND GENDER, NON
DISCRIMINATION, AUTOMOBILE
INSURANCE. HE ALSO PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE. IN ADDRESSING
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION OF LIFE
INSURANCE. PRIOR TO THIS
ADJOURNMENT. I CAN'T TELL YOU
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO HAVE
CONTACTED ME IN MY OFFICE AS A
MEMBER, AS I SAID OF THE
COMMISSION. ASKING. FOR US TO
CONDUCT THIS ADJOURNMENT TODAY
IN THIS MEMORIAL. BUT ALSO
SPEAKING. WITH SUCH FOND
REMEMBRANCE OF JEFF HE WAS
CERTAINLY SOMEBODY WHO TOUCHED
IN A POSITIVE WAY EVERYONE
AROUND HIM. HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HIS LOVE OF HIS
FAMILY. SPORTS AS THEY SAID IN
FILM, AS WELL AS HIS
FRIENDLINESS AND HIS SENSE OF
HUMOR. HE WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED TODAY. AND JEFF
MARGOLIS MEMORY THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ E. TO THE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS OF MR MARGOLIS. OUR
CONDOLENCES. SENATOR CORTEZ,
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
HE CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
IN THE SENATE JOURNAL. NEXT
STEP. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR FROM FAIR OAKS, SENATOR
NILO THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. ON
THIS, UH KIND OF ANNIVERSARY OF
HIS UNFORTUNATE AND UNTIMELY
PASSING. I RISE TO ASK ALL OF
YOU TO JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
THE MEMORY OF A LONGTIME FRIEND,
MENTOR. ADVOCATE AND HERO OF OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY, REX HEIM. HE
WAS A FIXTURE IN THIS ARENA FOR
NEARLY 50 YEARS. WHO BOTH
PROFESSIONALLY AND PERSONALLY
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF. AS A
FIERCE ADVOCATE AND CHAMPION OF
MANY CAUSES. IT'S WITH GREAT
SORROW AND TRUE SENSE OF
PERSONAL LOSS THAT WE ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY. LIKE MANY OF
YOU I WAS VERY LUCKY TO COUNT
MYSELF AS ONE OF REX PERSONAL
FRIENDS FOR A LOT OF YEARS. SO A
LITTLE ABOUT HIS PERSONAL
HISTORY THAT SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW, UH BUT IT'S REALLY QUITE
EXTENSIVE. HE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN CALIFORNIA. HE WENT TO
U. C DAVIS AND RECEIVED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND THEN ONTO THE U. C
DAVIS LAW SCHOOL WHERE A
RECEIVED A LAW DEGREE. HE THEN
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY
RESERVE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD, RETIRED. FROM
THAT IN 1990 AS A MAJOR. I KNOW
HE WAS VERY PROUD OF THAT
SERVICE. FOR MOST OF HIS CAREER,
WE HEAR ALL KNEW HIM AS THE
THAT'S THE FACE OF THE
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY
AS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION FOR 37 YEARS, ALMOST
FOUR DECADES IN THAT POSITION,
SPENT MUCH OF HIS LIFE WORKING.
FOR THE ADVOCACY OF THAT
INDUSTRY, BUT THAT'S ONLY A
PIECE. OF WHAT REX DID. BEFORE
JOINING CBP A. HE SERVED AS
GOVERNOR REAGAN'S EDUCATIONAL
STAFF MEMBER EDUCATION STAFF
MEMBER AND AS AN ASSISTANT TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
LATER. HE SERVED AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION, SPECIAL ASSISTANT
TO THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. AND
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AS THE
SENIOR ASSISTANT TO THE MINORITY
LEADER OF THE ASSEMBLY. BUT
THAT'S NOT ALL OUTSIDE OF ALL
THOSE JOBS. REX SERVED ON THE
TAHOE REGIONAL PLANNING
AUTHORITY. THE CALIFORNIA TASK
FOR FORCE ON VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AS A REGION OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND AS A TRUSTEE AND
CHAIR OF THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
AREA VALLEY LEUKEMIA AND
LYMPHOMA SOCIETY. HE ALSO SERVED
AS PRESIDENT OF THE U. C. DAVIS
ALUMNI ASSOCIATION AND IN
VARIOUS SUPPORTIVE CAPACITIES
FOR UH, THAT CAMPUS THAT HE
LOVED SO MUCH. HE IS WELL KNOWN
FOR HIS PASSION AND HIS
VOLUNTEER WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR, IN
PARTICULAR, FOR WHICH HE SERVED
AS CHAIR, VICE CHAIR AND BOARD
MEMBER AT CAL EXPO FOR MORE THAN
20 YEARS AND EARNED THE
DISTINCTION OF BEING THE ONLY
BOARD MEMBER. TO RECEIVE THE
APPOINTMENT BY FIVE. COUNT THEM
FIVE DIFFERENT GOVERNORS,
OBVIOUSLY FROM BOTH SIDES. OF
THE AISLE. TRULY A LIFE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. FAR BEYOND HIS
CHRONOLOGICAL YEARS. HE'S
STRONGLY VALUED HIS LONG
FRIENDSHIPS WITH PEOPLE, SOME OF
YOU IN HERE THAT MAY NOT HAVE
SHARED HIS VIEWS NECESSARILY.
BUT HE ALWAYS SHARED A LAUGH.
EVERYBODY LIKED REX. HE WAS
KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE HALLS OF
THE CAPITOL FOR WEARING HIS
TRADEMARK HAWAIIAN SHIRTS. THAT
WAS HIS FORMAL DRESS CODE
HAWAIIAN SHIRT. AND FOR HIS
REALLY NO NONSENSE, GOAL
ORIENTED APPROACH THAT STILL
LEFT THE ROOM WERE LEFT ROOM FOR
HIM TO CRACK A JOKE. HE LEFT AN
IMPRINT ON OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY
FOR SURE. UH HUH. AND HE LEFT US
FAR TOO SOON. FOR SURE. HE
LEAVES HIS PAST. IN HIS PASSING
HIS WIFE, GWEN, BICKER. HEIM,
WHO ALSO IS A MEMBER OF THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY, HER HIS THREE
SONS, REX, WILLIAM HÌNH, HIME,
REAGAN, STEWART TIME AND TREVOR
ANTHONY. PLEASURE AND ALL OF HIS
FRIENDS. FAMILIES. AND
COLLEAGUES. AH, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME IN A JOURNEY IN THE
MEMORY OF A GREAT GUY REX TÌM.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEAL O ON
THIS ITEM. WE RECOGNIZE SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I TOO WOULD LIKE TO, UH
JOURNAL, ALONG WITH MY FRIEND
FROM FAIR OAKS AND MEMORY OF REX
TIME WHO, UM IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING. UH, WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE ACTUALLY
FOR THIS SEAT. REX AND I RAN
AGAINST EACH OTHER. AND QUITE
FRANKLY, HE WAS JUST THAT A
GREAT GUY OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL. VERY RESPECTFUL, AND WE
HAD A FRIENDSHIP. BEFORE THAT.
HE ACTUALLY SUPPORTED ME FROM MY
RACES. AND THEN WE GOT TO RUN
AGAINST EACH OTHER AND HAD A FUN
TIME BEATING UP. ONE OF OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WHO'S NOW
IN CONGRESS. BUT WE HAD A GREAT
TIME TOGETHER. WE BOTH HAVE SONS
, THE NAMES OF REAGAN AND ALONG
THE WAY, SO I JUST WANTED TO,
UH, GIVE MY CONDOLENCES TO A
WONDERFUL, AWESOME FAMILY. AND
TO A FATHER AND A HUSBAND. WHO
WAS JUST A VERY RESPECTFUL,
GREAT GUY ALL AROUND, SO I
WANTED TO JUST STAND UP AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE HIM RECOGNIZE.
RECOGNIZE HIM AS WELL. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU, SENATOR DAHLE. MR.
HIMES WAS A FRIEND OF MANY HERE
ON THE FLOOR. UH SENATOR NILO.
IS THERE SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO
ADD? JUST THANK YOU ALL FOR
ALLOWING US TO PAY TRIBUTE TO A
GREAT GUY, REX HIÆN. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEAL. OH, I PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN BE A
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL. NEXT STEP. I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF MY
FORMER SORRY. NOT A FORMER
FRIEND, ALWAYS A FRIEND. BUT A
FORMER RICHMOND MAYOR IRMA
ANDERSON, WHO IS A TRAILBLAZER
AND VISIONARY AND DIED AT HOME
ON JANUARY 28TH. SHE WAS 93.
IRMA WAS THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN
TO BE ELECTED MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF RICHMOND, AND SHE WAS THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO BE ELECTED
TO SERVE ON THE RICHMOND CITY
COUNCIL. SHE'S THE ONLY BLACK
WOMAN THAT SERVED MAYOR UM FROM
HER DAYS WORKING IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT TO FIGHTING THE
AIDS EPIDEMIC AS A HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL, WHICH SHE WAS HER
ENTIRE CAREER TO HER
GROUNDBREAKING CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE. IRMA'S LEGACY WAS FAR
GREATER THAN HER 5 FT TWO
STATURE. HER SON AHMAD. ALWAYS
STATED FROM THE SMALL ACORN
COMES THE MIGHTY OAK. MY MOTHER
WAS THE GIANT AMONGST GIANTS.
SHE WAS A PILLAR FOR VOICES THAT
WERE UNREPRESENTED AND A
LIGHTHOUSE FOR FOLKS IN TROUBLED
WATERS. HER DEAR FRIEND, CONTRA
COSTA. SUPERVISOR JOHN GIOIA
NOTED THAT IRMA WAS STEADFASTLY
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
HEALTHCARE AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL OF RICHMOND'S RESIDENTS, BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. AND RICHMOND
. IF THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW MY
DISTRICT WHILE IT IS THE SECOND
LARGEST CITY IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY, IT IS VERY OFTEN IGNORED
AND SHE FOUGHT HARD FOR IT NEVER
TO BE IGNORED. JOHN SAID THAT
IRMA SAW ISSUES THROUGH THE LENS
OF COMMUNITY HEALTH. SHE WAS A
NURSE. SHE WAS THE FIRST THEORY
ADVOCATE, BUT SHE HAD A GREAT
BEDSIDE MANNER SHE CARED ABOUT
PEOPLE HE WAS BORN AND RAISED
NEAR BOSTON, AND SHE WAS VERY
KNOWN FOR HER BOSTON ACCENT,
WHICH HAS EVEN THOUGH SHE MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA IN THE FIFTIES.
THAT ACCIDENT WAS THICK. UM I'VE
MENTIONED HER FIRST AT RICHMOND
CITY HALL. BUT SHE COLLECTED A
NUMBER FIRST BEFORE SHE WAS EVEN
ELECTED TO ANY OFFICE IN
RICHMOND. SHE WAS VALEDICTORIAN
AND STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT OF
HER HIGH SCHOOL. HE EARNED TWO
NURSING DEGREES FROM CORNELL
UNIVERSITY. SHE WAS THE ONLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO GRADUATE IN
HER CLASS AT CORNELL. AND AFTER
MOVING TO CALIFORNIA, SHE GOT
HER MASTERS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT
UC BERKELEY. SHE WORKED AT THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. HE WAS THERE
FOR 20 YEARS, AS IN THE AS A
NURSE AT THAT DEPARTMENT, BUT
THEN WAS APPOINTED THAT HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FIRST BLACK PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING DIRECTOR IN 1983,
AND SHE HELD THAT POSITION FOR
OVER A DECADE. DURING HER LONG
CAREER IN PUBLIC HEALTH. SHE WAS
DEDICATED TO ERADICATING AND
BEING VERY UPFRONT ABOUT THINGS
LIKE THE SCOURGE OF AIDS AND NOT
HIDING IT, AND SHE ORGANIZED THE
WEST COUNTY AIDS TASK FORCE.
AND, OF COURSE IN HER COMMUNITY.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS REALLY
TRYING TO BE BURIED THAT, IN
OTHER WORDS, PEOPLE DID NOT WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT. AND SHE
UNDERSTOOD THAT IF WE DO NOT
TALK ABOUT IT, IF WE'RE NOT
UPFRONT ABOUT IT, THEN THAT MANY
MORE PEOPLE WOULD BE WOULD
ACTUALLY WE'RE WE'RE SPREADING
AIDS. AFTER HER RETIREMENT, IRMA
WAS ELECTED TO THE RICHMOND CITY
COUNCIL IN 82. AND LIKE ME, SHE
WAS VERY INSPIRED BY SHIRLEY
CHISHOLM. QUOTING AUTISM OFTEN
AND HER FAVORITE QUOTE WAS
SERVICE IS THE RENT. WE PAY FOR
THE PRIVILEGE OF LIVING ON THIS
EARTH. IRMA WAS CREDITED WHILE
SHE WAS AT RICHMOND CITY HALL
WITH INITIATING THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAM. IN RICHMOND THAT'S NOW
KNOWN AS THE OFFICE OF
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFETY. WHEN I WAS
ELECTED IN THE ASSEMBLY IN 2008
RICHMOND WAS THE MURDER CAPITAL
OF THE UNITED STATES. RICHMOND
TODAY HAS THE LOWEST HOMICIDE
RATE IT HAS HAD IN DECADES. AND
THE WORK OF THAT OFFICE AND
OTHER WORK THAT SHE INITIATED IS
THE REASON UM. WHEN HER HEALTH
STARTED TO FAIL, SHE GREETED THE
MOMENT WITH PEACE AND SAID, I
HAVE LIVED A GOOD LIFE. AND THAT
SHE DID, IRMA YOUR FAMILY, YOUR
FRIENDS AND I WILL DEEPLY MISS
YOU, AS WILL YOUR BELOVED CITY,
RICHMOND. AND THE EAST BAY AND I
ASKED THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN
IRMA ANDERSON'S MEMORY. THANK
YOU. SENATORS SKINNER FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL WORDS I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR
DODD. MR PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO
ADD MY VOICE TO THIS, UH,
WONDERFUL ADJOURNING MEMORY BY
MY GREAT COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY. IRMA. IT WAS A
WONDERFUL WOMAN. UH, I SERVED ON
THE. METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WITH IRMA FOR MANY
YEARS. AND SHE WAS AMAZING.
COMMISSIONER THE FIRST BLACK
COMMISSIONER ON EMPTY C AS WELL.
AND SHE WAS A FIERCE FIGHTER FOR
COACH COST COUNTY, A FIERCE
FIGHTER FOR THE CITY OF
RICHMOND. BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE, SHE WAS A COLLABORATOR.
COMING IN AND I WOULD CONSIDER
HER A GOOD FRIEND AND A LOT OF
FUN TO BE AROUND. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR SKINNER,
IF YOU WOULD BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN OUR JOURNAL.
MEMBERS IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE SENATE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE PRO TEM MCGUIRE,
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MR PRESIDENT, SENATE WILL
BE ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY. AND I
HAVE THE DATE OF MONDAY MONDAY,
FEBRUARY 12TH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN MEMBERS AS WE
ADJOURNED TODAY, PLEASE KEEP IN
YOUR HEARTS. THE FIVE MARINES
WHO WERE WHO WERE KILLED. SO.
WAY BEYOND THEIR TIME. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
330 PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY AT TWO PM MEMBERS.